ciao corso scrivere la mia domanda è una
domanda che restare almeno all'antica
grecia
sono certo però che in oscuri e
resistere l'amicizia ex dipende
tantissimo come vi siete lasciati
certo dipende anche tantissimo secondo
me dai motivi per cui vi siete lasciati
se vi siete lasciati per vari motivi ma
tra questi non c'è il fatto che non
fosse più attratti l'uno dall'altra
allora è già più difficile secondo me
capito senza c'è anche un pezzo in
jurassic park in cui proprio 2 t rex
stanno così non sei troppo fuori tu sì
voglio perché sono un artista generoso e
comunque già il fatto che tu lo
chiedessi vuol dire che sotto sotto ti
aspettavi che la risposta e sperare che
fosse no mai capitato teggiamento mirino
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è la posta del cuore
parte 2
ci siamo presi una pausa perché
veramente stavamo facendo una roba
infinita e siamo tornati quindi direi a
questo punto di metterci ad ascoltare i
paesaggi di vedere un pochino che cosa
hanno da dire ciao ciao ospite chiunque
tu sia la posta del cuore potresti darmi
un consiglio su come far lasciare tutto
ragazzo perché ho una cotta per luigi ed
è troppo bello ma anche molto bello però
origine ancora di più grazie
niente grazie in anticipo possiamo
vedere il profilo sempre questo ragazzo
che magari mi fai un favore me lo toglie
dalle
carne fresca non vuoi il prosciutto
stagionato
ok grazie il prossimo grazie mille
sveglia gente di mattina
io sono felicemente innamorata
il mio miglior amico gay da quando come
quattro anni cioè un volo della madonna
veramente chiarito che fuori è perfetto
so che mi venivano a ragione magari
chiesto fatti una ragione trovare un
chiodo che non sia interessato ad altri
chiodi che schiacci il chiodo che è
interessato ad altri chiodi nella vita
chiodo schiaccia chiodo in questo caso
stai cercando di martellare un chiodo
interessato trap i chiodi quindi trovano
in mente è stato molto quadro quello che
i vostri amici gay non li cambiate
parecchio dura e tosta
anzi anche per loro è tosta poi cercare
di svincolarsi e farvi capire intendere
bene mettete nella condizione di
tranquillità
fate i tanti complimenti che loro per le
piace tempo complimenti non facile e ti
faccio presente nel messaggio
dell'attenzione dai ciao ciao ospite
ogni tanto io penso di aver provato
tutto quello che posso provare e tutte
le relazioni che avrò da adesso in poi
saranno tutte una versione inferiore di
quello che ho effettivamente già provato
esco da una situazione di cinque anni
con il mio migliore amico che è finita
in un modo abbastanza brutto firme non
c'era niente che non andava in quella
relazione e quindi mi chiedo se riuscirà
a riavere mai lo stesso livello di
confidenza come un'altra persona grazie
a questo messaggio un pochino mi batte
il cuore devo esser sincero 6 gradi
qualcosa stavo cercando di pezzetti del
tuo cuoricino trovare una persona che ti
fa innamorare fa perdere la testa in
maniera così potente da farti mettere in
dubbio di poter trovare di nuovo una
persona che sia anche solo simile
secondo me essere una fortuna che una
sfortuna è una sfortuna perché come ho
detto due effettivamente ti mette
diciamo in quella condizione di
insicurezza e di paura resa
meglio la fortuna però è anche quella
che ti fa esattamente capire che cosa
vuoi che cosa non vuoi il mio invito è
prima di tutto quello di non disperare
secondo se molto giovane non credo che
tu possa aver visto il meglio e il
peggio ma secondo me non c'è mai fine al
meglio al peggio
la cosa però che devi capire che ora è
una consapevolezza più grande non ti
accontenterai io so perchè perchè hai
diciamo un'asticella emotiva e interiore
molto più alta e ci sta stare da soli e
ci sta aspettare ci sta anche cercare
nel momento in cui si ottiene questa
consapevolezza
l'amore è una fortuna secondo me io sono
del parere che nell'arco di una vita
sono degli innamoramenti no nel senso il
primo e l'innamoramento un po giovanile
un po che comunque ti fa perdere la
testa quindi che ti fa anche un po sì sì
per falsificare il secondo è quello che
ti fa capire realmente cosa vuoi no ti
metti discussione mette in discussione
il terzo diciamo che potrebbe essere
quello che
hai scelto liberamente di veste ed
appartiene il quarto e quello dopo il
divorzio provarci apertamente con una
persona ma devo chiederti un consiglio
riguardo acquisto
in questo è il ragazzo grazie si
risponde rai e un abbraccio a te è alto
ospite allora tacco alto scollatura il
dg cosa posso mai sparato scusa non so
perché mi sento cosi pronti oggi così io
sono esattamente come te io piuttosto
che provarci in morirei mi ammazzerà io
credo che sia un pochino come il
paracadutismo il primo salto ti
terrorizza pensi di morire ma in realtà
quando ti rendi conto poi che alla fine
sotto sotto non muori perché comunque a
terry col paracadute e quello che hai
avuto semplicemente un brivido di un
momento fine il secondo il terzo il
quarto il quinto diventano molto più
semplice all'interno della testa di una
persona che è molto più tranquilla nell
approcciarsi c'è anche secondo me
un'analisi molto più tranquilla riguardo
al no
cioè se una persona ti dice guarda non
sono interessata non vuol dire che se
non a dire semplicemente che non c'è un
interesse reciproco quindi amen però
possono essere mille motivazioni si
secondo me devi caricare e questo lo
dico anche a me per quando poi ci dovrà
provare visto che ormai lui ha già
trovato un'altra persona secondo me
bisogna incominciare ad affrontare in
maniera più leggere queste situazioni
perché più tempo si aspetta prima di
aprire bocca e più ci si caricano le
guance di parole e cose non diedi e di
significati e di pensieri e quindi alla
fine diventa ovviamente più difficile
invece riuscire da subito a pertica
strano magari anzi sarà inutile persino
e automaticamente non riuscire da subito
a essere un pochino più trasparenti
senza però essere krypi cioè non è che
devi dire
secondo me è un modo anche migliore per
vivere in generale i sì e in 8 d'accordo
gran due di picche
se ti beccano due di picche io ho
beccato due di picche sorta io non ti
prego riesch altissima in brodo di
giuggiole fandonie per favore ciao
allora in realtà io non ho nessuna
relazione strana situazione assurda
anzi sono tre anni quasi ormai che sto
insieme alla mia ragazza e una persona
più bella del mondo ma l'unica cosa è
che vorrei chiederle di sposarmi e
magari posso usare te se ti va di
mandare questo vocale e farle sentire
visto che ti porta anche lei che la
vorrei sposare abbiamo un messaggio da
costanza per giada come c'è posta per te
giada tu stai insieme a questa ragazza
che si chiama costanza da tre anni tutto
va bene e c'è solamente una cosa che ti
vorrebbe chiedere costanza quindi la
domanda è già da nico e sposare
io faccio un momento di silenzio per
farti prendere io non è mai capitato una
cosa così via
che bella della mare complimenti ragazzi
congratulazioni giada rispondi c'é qua
sotto
ti prego se metti un commento incitiamo
ma che cosa comunque di dizzy giada
spero che in questo momento loro abbiano
chiuso il nostro video e siano facendo
altro comunque stiano perdendo se sono
in fischiando di quello che diremo noi
quindi ragazzi meno costanza e giada
continuiamo con questo video lumi eletto
grazie cui sono emozionatissima grazie
davvero giostra paura te lo credo prima
di te non credo fateci sapere come va su
instagram qua sotto il commento fatecelo
sapere
bella persona che say no to say
meravigliosa meriti la felicità ce la
posso fare
ciao ciao innanzitutto volevo farmi i
complimenti per il coraggio di voler
affrontare questo tema e venire perché
tre strade con il mio con lasciato la
casa da quattro anni di una relazione
dopo un attacco di panico abbastanza
forte ma no non la devo di aver mai
racconta di avere tutti ma sono in cura
da una psicologa che guardi a prendere
farmaci stima che ci attacchino in
qualche strada sta bene e fatto è che
l'ho lasciato e sono tre mesi che gli ho
chiesto di tenere insieme ma niente
ancora indecisi ma io non so che fare
perché lo amo che l'asp lettere anche
tutta una vita ma chi è sto troppo male
e fare consigli penso che quando
dall'altra parte si ha a che fare una
persona che non riesce a rendersi conto
che molte le cose che vengono dette
quando si sta male spesso non sono per
forza quelle che pensiamo e che si possa
star male senza bisogno di avere
qualcosa di fisico addosso dentro il
nostro corpo manca semplicemente dentro
la nostra protesta quando ci si
relaziona una persona così secondo me ci
si relaziona una persona che ha paura
dell'ignoto del dire ok ci diamo una
seconda possibilità
poi succede di nuovo e se poi c'è un
qualcosa per cui tu mi lasci non posso
sapere che cosa sia stato detto che cosa
non sia stato detto e anche la paura che
possa fare il rendersi conto di quanto
un problema possa cambiare possa pesare
esatto all'interno di una situazione io
spero veramente che tu possa più che
altro trovare un canale di comunicazione
con questa persona specialmente perché
sei una persona che si sta aiutando
affrontando il processo questa roba qui
sia assolutamente io so quanto possa
essere debilitante quello che stai
passando ma non lo possono sapere tutti
esatto cerca di farlo entrare nel tuo
mondo e ti auguro veramente di trovare
le giuste parole
già il fatto che in un certo senso lei
comunque sia affidata a persone
competenti che la stanno aiutando un
anno pensavo a noi due
scusami a non avere il tempo cioè che
scherzi scherza è un gran passo né e
quindi secondo me questa roba da da
prendere in considerazione da parte del
ragazzo che mi piace un sacco
non so come fare per farglielo capire ci
conosciamo dalla prima elementare il
danno iniziato a uscire in gruppo
insieme mi scrive mi chiese non vi siano
i passaggi vanno a prendere io lì ma non
so se magari soffre sempre lui perché
gentile o poche facce cioè come faccio
con è ospite ex però sono tutte
bellissime fratelli giovedì dall inizio
questa cosa ma certo il carina job
l'idea
io sono dell'idea che esiste un tempo
per ogni cosa esiste un tempo per
analizzare un tempo per agire ma poi nel
momento in cui analisi troppo esiste
anche un tempo in cui incominciano a
crearsi draghi nella testa delle persone
il salto da mi ha dato un passaggio a mi
ha accompagnato a lunedì martedì
mercoledì the di sabato incomincia a
diventare di colpo un calco
con l'autore incomincerei le teorie del
complotto che i terapisti ciao in
confronto il mio consiglio è quello
anche di non perdere troppo tempo a
creare delle sovrastrutture oa dare
delle motivazioni assurde a dei gesti
che magari sono più semplici quindi con
tutta la faccia di iniziare ad aprire un
pochino discorso per quanto sia
difficile e il problema è che fra due
mesi tu stai guida calcolare lo smalto
che si mette alle unghie dei piedi per
capire se dello stesso colore dei tuoi
occhi perché fidati esistono storie di
persone che sono state freddo è nata una
vita io io tra quelli come allegato e
non avevano mai tirato fuori i loro
sentimenti e quando l'hanno fatto ce
l'hanno fatta però infinita
cercavo di darle 1 vinta non era modo
per mancarti rispetto cioè vogliamo
uccidere la così non sarà questo è il
messaggio delle persone che dicono
complimenti per il tatto lui non è gay
vero se mette lo smalto dello stesso
colore è probabile se non è gay
allora procede col piano anche se è gay
al mini mite dire al tesoro se fossi
stato etero ti avrei amata ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questa puntata io
vi ringrazio di cuore per esservi
prestati a questo esperimento e
soprattutto devo dire che personalmente
lo sa che mi è piaciuta tantissimo
potrebbe essere una delle mie preferite
fatemi sapere se questa forma di vita
buttata non per forza dal punto di vista
di riporto guarano reo ma chiacchiera un
pochino più tranquilla e confidenziale
vi piace e se vi è piaciuta in questo
caso fatemi soprattutto sapere se
ascoltando alcune di queste storie avete
dei consigli per per i ragazzi per le
ragazze delle cose morali quali non
abbiamo pensato o magari delle cose che
voi pensate in maniera diversa insomma
in modo da poter dare anche più opzioni
di occasioni più pareri a cover e chi ci
ha mandato i suoi vocali come sempre vi
invito a iscrivervi a questo canale
attivare le notifiche se non volete
perdervi nessun video
ringrazio voi ringrazio ten se ringrazio
amore e che dire ci vediamo il prossimo
giovedì sempre alle 14 con un'altra
puntata evita puntata ciao ragazzi
comunque è comunque vadano queste cose
io voglio
minchia